I want the truth
because I seem to find myself
in the position where I'm always seem to
be the side bit side
um all the time
and I think that's just what annoys me
like
do you think you give us side chick
Vibes yeah like I just don't seem to
find someone that just wants but do you
know he's in a relationship when you
meet him no otherwise I wouldn't go
there oh okay so it's different yeah I
just get put in a position where I find
out like months
in one case two years
um that they've been in a relationship
so I just want the truth because it
doesn't hurt me like you could turn
around say oh this is not serious and
I'd be like it is what it is I want to
have my fun but if why do you think they
put you in that box
I think because I don't necessarily come
I don't come across like I want to have
something serious okay so as much as I
do I'm like in between because I've had
bad experiences before which has made me
feel like I don't want no one to live
with me I don't want this I don't want
that but then it comes to I do feel
lonely and I would want that intimacy
and that love from the right person do
you think then that's in a way making
the mistakes of the man of the future
pay for the mistakes of your past
it's kind of like when it's kind of like
when a guy is is always going through
your phone because some girl cheated on
him
in a way
see I always say this rule I won't go
through your phone don't go through my
phone that's going to hurt you don't you
think that before you move on to one
relationship like get rid of the baggage
heal from one before you go don't take
one relationship into the other
can I say I've I've clocked that we've
all been saying honesty but I feel like
personally if you yearn for but like
honesty in a relationship is kind of
like it kind of sucks because like if
you're going to relationship being like
I just want honesty I need you to be
honest with me I need you to be honest
with me it's kind of like do you need to
beg for that but also at the end of the
day I don't know about you guys but
personally for someone that's been
honest with me I have felt hurt before
and it's kind of like also that honestly
doesn't I feel like there's certain
things that you don't have to say
there's certain things that you don't
have to say well if you say it's gonna
cause some type of some type of you know
and also can I say guys that are always
honest they're normally always honest
about their past relationships and I
feel like
if you if you if you've established that
you guys are going to be a hundred
percent about everything you've done
you're going to feel some type of way
regardless of whether that involved you
or not so they've been doing stuff
before they even knew you but you'd feel
the tap away because they're with you
right now so it's kind of like certain
stuff you don't have to say and it's not
me being secretive if there's certain
stuff that we can talk about we can talk
about that's going to progress our
relationship but if it's about oh like
yeah I used to do like this with her and
like yeah like this and that I think
it's kind of like I think you're right I
don't think women want honesty but yeah
because then they wouldn't keep dating
Liars yeah did you get you'd sit down
and be like yeah
just cry and be mad and then just get
over it my first react I always say tell
me the honest truth let the first
reaction go over the head because that's
it soaking in yeah that's the honesty
Progressive relationship is it positive
to your relationship though yes because
they know that there's no point in lying
to me I'm not the one you want to lie to
and why did you say honesty when I asked
when you I asked you what you were
looking for because to me that implies
that maybe you haven't always gotten
that no I haven't
um the past relationships
well because you're a pretty girl you
have a million options there's many men
that will be honest with you but it's
like we pick the Liars no they I don't
know I just feel like they as you said
make more funny so right it's like the
Liars the lies make you want them but
then you're attracted to the life yeah
so but I do with the truth it'd be nice
so then what incentive do men have to be
honest with us if the Liars get laid I
just prefer like if you just turn around
and said yeah you're seeing talking to
like two free other girls and I'm just
an option if they told you that then
they then you wouldn't sleep with them
that kind of links back to what I said
earlier
um a lot of time and this has been
mentioned on fresh and fair another
podcast
um when one honestly honest day but
as the saying goes they can't really
handle the truth because when you are
honest
they immediately leave which you know I
understand what what incentive is
they're for men to be honest because
they'll lose the resources they put into
you you know whether it's taking on
dates life advice everything because men
help us with a lot of things when we're
with them
um but then you just leave because
they're with other people which is most
likely the thing that they're not being
honest about
um so as you said what incentive do they
have to be honest when they could lose
the whole thing they've put working on
like you must be crazy to not tell me
something that you know I'm gonna be
like yeah I'm Gonna Leave You for it's
kind of like what people are selfish I
mean do you do you go into relationships
telling when your body count
well it depends anyone ever asked I've
never been asked because never I don't
know because I feel like any guy that
you talk to these day will ask you your
body count really no really you're not
anymore maybe like two years not anymore
he's right it's a young person it's like
the younger the younger the guys yeah
maybe it's because yeah but I'm just
saying if we're gonna be a hundred
percent honest yeah no because I feel
like a lot because especially right like
a lot of girls are with guys where they
know if they said their body count it
would end their relationship so so like
there's there's in a way we're not
always honest with them either because I
was gonna say like if you're going into
a relationship nowadays especially like
my friends everybody that I'm surrounded
by right now as a 19 year old they will
100 ask your body count 100 it's one of
the first thing that comes up what's
your name what school do you go what's
your favorite color what's your body
count it's definitely the age maybe it's
the age thing but in this like in this
day and age right now that I'm in right
now they will ask you with no shame
because when you answer that's the
question will you answer 100 I'll be
straight up baby I'll say this many or
this name I've never had anybody else
older men just don't see the point in
asking yeah they just feel like you're
gonna lie anyway you're right but the
last time I ever got asked that question
I think I was 16 years old that's a good
nine years ago really because
I lied I did get answers our husbands
all the time right now and I did give my
honest answer I think with men as well
um obviously you know you can't look at
a woman and be like oh yeah her body
can't exists but you can get an inkling
of whether it's higher or lower and
sometimes that is enough to suffice them
as to whether they get in a relationship
or just have sex you or whatever it may
be I think how you portray yourself is
sometimes enough for them to decide
would it put you off of this if their
body count was like higher than yours
no of course not you know I think men
value inexperience with whereas women
value experience so my partner's body
characters of course higher than mine
and if it wasn't I'd be like why the
hell am I with you if no one else wants
you but did the young lady on the end I
don't see I don't know I don't think
that I don't agree with that but I just
expect men you don't agree with what
that um you think it's because the
experience I I don't think you don't
think women value experience no no I do
think they value experience but I don't
think I'd be saying oh your body count
is less than mine so I don't like that
because other women don't like you okay
I mean I don't know that's a conscious
thing but I mean yeah I don't I don't
sit there and think of myself well these
women didn't you've got a low body count
therefore these women didn't like you so
why am I it's just you know a silent
tick in your head where it's you know
it's like Evolution
it's like when a guy's very I mean one
of guys will tell me getting verified is
the first way to get women yeah because
it's a sign of pre-selection
so superficial though isn't it I mean we
can't really change it yeah it's like
it's like telling the world not to be
the world and all in all of history like
women have gone for men that other women
have selected so it's like you can say
it's superficial but that's that's
always what happens yeah like look at um
you know Genghis Khan all the world's
conquerors if women didn't like men that
weren't if women did not like men that
were experienced why do these men that
you have harms of women women just
naturally gravitate 17 women reproduced
for one man every one man eight thousand
years ago
has to say crazy girls can get who they
want and guys get what they want no
girls get what they want guys get like
if a guy can only get a girl if the girl
wants them he can't just go out and get
the girl girls
can get who they can I see um sorry guys
sorry
um I feel like just we were talking
about there's like a couple seconds ago
but like I feel like women always say
they want to experience someone who's
experienced
but we'll cry if they find out who
they've been in those experiences with
and how many body count there is can I
just say it because I could say and be
like I want someone who's so experienced
that's going to do this that's going to
do that and make me feel this type of
way but then as soon as okay cool that
happens and they're like okay cool
what's your body can't who have you been
in for the past they're gonna start
crying and it's kind of like
choose choose whether you want him to be
experienced and and like is that common
100 just don't have to start asking I
just want to hear if you're doing that
scared the question about what she wants
in a man oh yeah what do you look for
what do I look for Animals yes
um I feel like even though I'm quite
small
I'd say like five eight um sorry I'm
like five three I've got two little
people yeah
normally I feel short next to Pearl I
feel tall today
um I like command that's family very big
on like family
um big family
I like chivalry
I don't really have like a type like
physically so he's got to be five eight
and he likes his family in Chivalry well
he's nice yeah he's got good family and
he's chivalrous what about money
any minimum what if he's unemployed
are you paying the bills till till he
figures it just it depends on how much
passion he has and what he's doing
that's not paying the bills
it's like really a big thing usually
unemployed people don't have passion
typically
I'll tell you all right welcome to
England
so are we all going to say like money is
a big thing in relationship going into a
relationship right now like yeah money
is a big thing
I've heard everybody mention everything
and for me all I want is a man that's
working that's going to treat me the
same way you like to be treated and he's
got to be good in bed
I ain't gonna have no money I don't care
what you look like I don't care how tall
you are if you're not good in but it
ain't happening I don't care how much
money you've got either if you know and
everybody's talking talking about this
funny flattering that funny fluttering
and nobody said about sex what but so
your fanny can flatten the man's gonna
tell me he ain't gonna be good in bed
what are you gonna do then he's got
everything else that's in the shopping
surely except that because now you put
that you need to put that in the
shopping Julie I missed that off but
that is vital absolutely do you guys
rather have a guy that you weren't
physically attracted to that's good and
bad or a guy that you were very
physically attracted to but he was bad
and bad give me the number not physical
yeah I don't mind because I feel like if
you're not good in bed I can always do
that kind of bit myself
so you you would take the hot guy
yeah you take the Hawkeye what about you
I think I think I'd have to be attracted
to him to some degree to be able to lay
down so I'd have to teach I think rather
than not have an attractive man no
there's no word this isn't build a man
he's bad in bed today he's gonna be bad
in bed tomorrow
he does not care give her one yes
60 seconds that's it
I mean I think that's important for me
that would have to be good in bed so
but then I wouldn't be able to lay with
somebody if I didn't find them
attractive
you have to
be ugly and good in bed and good looking
and rubbish
he didn't tell me that you can't go out
of an ugly man
is that how superficial you are what I
mean
I think um
it's tough I can't answer I said I never
got that because I always if you get an
ugly man nobody's gonna want him you've
got a whole man for yourself
but then he's not making my fanny
flutter so then it's not but they're
doing it for me so I think I would have
to I would have to yeah maybe but then I
have to look at him it's the good
looking to have to look he has to be
attractive to me and how many hours a
day are you looking at each other versus
how many hours a day are you sleeping
with each other
if you're working if you're going out
together you see it you it's yeah how
many days how many hours a day do you
work about eight how many hours a day do
you sleep about eight that's what you've
got to think about so you're only gonna
see him back before and depending on
sexual positions you don't even have to
look at him
I think
I think I'd have to go with with the
good looking guy that's superficial
isn't it but I think I would have to
yeah most women would there yeah I think
okay would anyone take the the not so
good looking guy we're good in bed me
you too and then you would take the
Hawkeye yeah I've actually been with
someone that's not good looking but
there was good in bed and in after a
while it's like my mind just started
saying to me they're good looking it's
all right
fine
makes up for it in the beds no I go for
the person that's unattractive but good
in bed because you can learn to love
someone's appearance even if they don't
change you can just gradually learn to
love it whereas sex is quite an intimate
part of relationship so even though it's
not as important for women as it is for
men generally
um it's that'll still be a part of your
relationship missing as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible